this week you get to go back to Hyrule
in HD and relive life as a wolf hanging
out with midna you'll run through nine
dangerous dungeons to collect light
spirits and save Zelda you get enhanced
graphics thanks to Tantalus media and
there's also the tempting edition of
this fancy amiibo with a really witty
story and one of the more darker and
beautiful versions of high rolled is an
excellent Zelda for both longtime fans
and the first time Twilight Princess
player you can grab this on the 4th you
also get to go back to the familiar and
creepy tale of the origami killer in
heavy rain you remember this lovely tale
right the criminal abducts a young boy
during the rainy fall season after which
their body is found several days later
in a remote location drowning being the
cause of death along with an origami
animal figure in their hands and an
orchid on their chest your families on
the line you have to find your son
before time is out this super popular
game won a lot of warns back in 2010 and
now it's coming out on ps4 for your
enjoyment you can grab that March first
also this week action Hank is coming to
ps4 and xbox one from Steam you want to
know what it's like well it's basically
the speed of Sonic mixed with the body
of Greg Miller Hank used to be the
fastest of them all back in the 80s and
90s but nowadays there's not much left
of his former glory he gets challenged
by his rival and now he's out to prove
that he's still got what it takes to be
a fastest gotta go fast on the floor
also this week we get broforce on ps4
and if you got PS Plus you get it for
free when evil threatens the world the
world calls on bro force an underfunded
overpowered paramilitary organization
dealing exclusively in excessive force
and bro puns you can download that on
the first of March and if you've been
waiting for far cry primal to get on pc
your wait is over as expected it's
gorgeous now you can ride mammoths and
control owls with stunning
resolution advil a survival of your
hunting group you're going to learn to
craft a deadly arsenal fend off fierce
predators and outsmart enemy tribes to
conquer the land of oros and become the
apex predator that's out on the first
and one on one fighter Mortal Kombat X
will return to xbox one and playstation
4 this week in a package that collects
all previously released dlc and bonus
content its mortal kombat XL it includes
all bonus content featured in the
downloadable combat pack and combat pack
to add ons along with the core Mortal
Kombat X game most notably the first
combat pack contains Jason Voorhees the
lovable slasher from the Friday the 13th
film franchise so you're going to want
to pick this one up and that's out on
the first and finally the only game
that's not an HD remake or port is
probably outlines gun it's a
third-person stealth game each level is
nonlinear and design featuring multiple
ways of completing tasks the plot
features around historical events such
as the Bay of Pigs invasion and the
assassination of US president john f
kennedy the game allows players to
choose between straightforward shootouts
or more subtle stealth oriented gameplay
you also get the ability to use items
like poison and you can do things like
staged accidents whoops you're dead you
can grab this on march first and that's
about it for this week release dates are
based on Reese your listings and they're
subject to change see you next week